since he first rode onto the screen as
carl drogo in game of thrones
jason mamoa has become one of the
world's biggest actors
still there are some things that most
people don't know about him so we are
taking a deep dive
into the life of the aquaman star
during his pre-acting days as a model
jason momoa says that he was often
referred to as pretty however
starting with his role in conan the
barbarian he's seen much more as a
ruggedly handsome
rough around-the-edges type of actor so
what changed
part of it might be a scary event in
2008 that gave momoa the prominent scar
on his eyebrow he told access hollywood
that he was at a bar and a man
approached him suddenly mammal was
smashed in the face with a pint glass
he had to get over 140 stitches and have
multiple surgeries to repair the damage
he believes it was some sort of gang
initiation as the attack occurred with
no provocation
talking about the jagged line running
across his eyebrow
mamoa further explained to access
hollywood that it might have helped his
career
he said it helped me get those mean
roles
mamoa has mentioned plenty of times that
it was love at first sight for him when
he laid eyes on his wife
in an interview on the late late show
with james corden he explained that he
first saw lisa bonet on the cosby show
when he was a kid
he was smitten with her immediately even
though it would be almost two decades
until the two
actually met in person i've always
wanted to meet her and i was
she was a queen always the way mamoa
tells it a mutual friend introduced the
two
at a jazz club in 2005 and they hit it
off almost
instantly they've basically been a
couple ever since and had their first
child together in 2007
and a second just a few years later the
couple got married in 2017
finally making it official since momoa
and bonai are married that also
officially makes zoe kravitz his
stepdaughter
zoe is bonai's daughter with her
previous husband musician and actor
lenny kravitz
though momoa started to make a name for
himself in film and television when he
was just a teenager
it wasn't until 2011 that he first
gained mainstream attention
that was when he burst onto the scene as
carl drogo on hbo's game of thrones
up until that point mamoa was generally
known for playing less
savage characters so he knew that he'd
have to do something impressive to land
the role
in an interview with the new york times
mamoa explained that drogo was a tough
character to portray
the leader of the dothraki is a man of
few words so momoa knew he would have to
demonstrate his powerful energy in a
different way
when he showed up for his audition he
decided to begin with a haka a maori war
dance
he hoped to show that he had the ability
to be as physically impressive
as the rule needed his heart was beating
so fast afterward that the rest of the
audition was difficult but he apparently
made enough of an impression to land the
role that changed
his life while momoa broke into the
mainstream as call drogo
his biggest role to date is probably in
the dc cinematic universe
where he plays aquaman the dc films
generally aren't met with quite the
universal praise that the marvel
cinematic universe
is but the film featuring momoa's turn
as the ruler of the seas
is regarded as one of the best films
that dc has put out
but before he became aquaman also known
as arthur
curry mamoa actually had several other
roles where he spent a lot of time
in the surf he grew up in hawaii and had
a successful career as a model before
auditioning for baywatch
where he played a young lifeguard named
jason until the series went off the air
he even returned for the tv movie
baywatch
hawaiian wedding mamoa also had a lead
role on north shore a series about an
exclusive resort hotel which was also
set in hawaii
aquaman wasn't even the first time mamoa
had been to atlantis he played run on
decks on stargate atlantis for several
seasons
which is probably the job that started
garnering him more attention before he
landed high-profile roles
and conan the barbarian and game of
thrones
we tend to imagine that once someone
becomes a household name
they're financially set for the rest of
their lives unfortunately that's
oftentimes not the case
for proof look no further than jason
momoa mamoa had a few acting roles that
gained exposure before bursting into the
big time in game of thrones but while
drogo was a major character in the debut
season of that series
it's important to remember that momoa
was in fewer than a dozen episodes
it was also the first season of the show
before it gained complete mainstream
saturation so it's not like mamoa was
off making quoting crowns for himself
after his time when the series ended in
fact the opposite is true momoa has
stated that he was totally broke and
struggling to pay bills
the actor told in style i mean we were
starving after game of thrones
i couldn't get work it's very
challenging when you have babies
and you're completely in debt obviously
momoa and his family are in a much
better financial situation now as he's
hardly struggling to land major parts
in addition to his ongoing role as
aquaman mamoa is involved with plenty of
other big productions like dune
it seems he'll be a part of the a-list
for quite some time
and he doesn't need to worry about
keeping the lights on anymore
mamoa often has his shirt off for his
roles and that's not a fact that many
people are going to complain about
however
that can make it tough to tell how many
of his tattoos are real and how many are
added to give his characters
a bit more personality well if you're
wondering some but not all of the
tattoos you see on momoa's characters
are very real the most obviously real
one is often visible in his public
appearances mamoa has a tribal pattern
on his left forearm it's a tribute to
his hawaiian roots
and it's designed to resemble shark's
teeth on the inside of his other arm
mamoa has the phrase pride of gypsies
inscribed he also has a french phrase on
that same arm which translates to
always be drunk mamoa also has a few
hand tattoos
including a skull near his thumb and the
word diablo
on his finger finally he has the
signatures of his two children on his
chest
and just in case anyone is wondering
mamoa's young kids have yet to follow in
their father's footsteps
you haven't actually tattooed your
children
[Music]
graham i haven't tattooed my children
that's all right
not only does mamoa spend plenty of time
in the surf as aquaman but he also has a
real world interest in marine biology
after moving to iowa momoa was actually
studying to become a marine biologist he
later transferred to colorado state and
focused on wildlife biology
however mamoa didn't wind up finishing
his degree he returned to hawaii where
he was cast
in baywatch from here his acting career
took off
still it's a fascinating turn of events
that the man who ended up as aquaman at
one point
studied marine life it seems likely that
his knowledge of sea life influenced his
performance
as he might have a better understanding
of what life in the ocean is like more
than the average actor
mamoa is known to be a bit of a party
animal who enjoys a drink or two in his
down time
and if you take a quick look at his
instagram page it's pretty obvious that
his beverage of choice is guinness
that love of the irish stout apparently
runs both ways as guinness decided to
create a beer specifically for him
it's called mono brew and it's the
company's first sour beer
the label is adorned with a few touches
that surely made the big man proud
hawaiian flowers and a leaping shark
decorate the label
along with a motif that's reminiscent of
momoa's forearm tattoo
in addition the actor's signature is
prominent across the label
entertainment weekly writes that he
shared pints of the irish brew with game
of thrones showrunners d.b weiss and
david benioff while they were on set
in northern ireland it doesn't appear
that mono brew is publicly available at
this point
but that didn't stop mamoa from sharing
some with the cast of aquaman when they
paid a visit to conan o'brien
in fact conan seemed a little in awe of
mamoa's guinness connection
how does that work how does one go to a
bar and say i'll have a guinness when
they start to pour it go no
the mamoa guinea how does that happen
charisma and a commanding screen
presence are pretty apparent qualities
of jason momoa it's tough to take your
eyes off of him whenever he shows up in
a film or tv show the actor also has
plenty of artistic talent to share when
he's behind the camera
he started his own production company in
2010 called pride of
gypsies the name refers to a pride of
lions and a gypsy
as a nomadic or free-spirited person so
the company sees their identity as an
adventurous collective
of filmmakers they've shot a few
trailers for television series
like frontier and they've worked with
carhartt for a number of commercials
over the last few years
they've also made three feature films so
far 2014's road to paloma 2018's braven
and the 2021 release
sweet girl though momoa is the name
behind the production company
the only feature he's directed so far is
row 2 paloma but we're sure he has
plenty of upcoming projects that he'd
love to take on
part of momoa's draw in playing powerful
characters like carl drogo and
aquaman comes from the fact that he's a
bit banged up
we already mentioned that he obtained
his prominent eyebrow scar from an
unfortunate incident at a bar however
that isn't the only injury that altered
momoa's appearance and gives his
characters a bit more grit
after being cast in the role of conan
the barbarian
mamoa reportedly told a friend of his
that he would look more like the
character if he had a broken
nose taking this as an invitation
mamoa's buddy punched him in the face
helping him to instantly achieve his
desired appearance
in fact when you take a close look at
some of the footage from conan
it appears that mamoa's profile isn't
quite picture perfect and he seems to be
more than okay with that
i dig it momoa plays a lot of tough guys
and he certainly looks the part he's
naturally a really big guy standing at
6'4
and boasting a physique that makes it
seem realistic that he can take on an
army of enemies
that said momoa isn't much of a gym rat
he tends to prefer more practical
workouts to lifting weights
in fact the star reportedly hates the
gym momoa's workout of choice
is climbing it's something he enjoys
doing and it helps him get the physique
he needs for his physically demanding
roles
speaking with men's health mamoa
explained that he has quote
a really hard time training for vanity
still looking like a superhero is part
of his job
for the aquaman shoot the studio had a
rock climbing gym built for the actor to
train on
and he says it kept him quote in a
beautiful place
mamoa also talked to men's health about
staying motivated
if you're passionate about something you
don't need pushing
you can push yourself it isn't terribly
hard to picture jason momoa as a metal
head with his long flowing hair and
imposing stature he looks like he'd be
right at home in the center of a mosh
pit
so it should come as no surprise that
momoa has regularly
rocked out to metal bands such as
pantera and slayer
he even claimed in an instagram post
that call drogo wouldn't exist
if it weren't for the inspiration of
bands like pantera
that post included photos from outside a
slayer show which momoa and his two
children
attended they weren't content to just
stay in the crowd however
momoa actually got on stage and rocked
out with the band
he later went into the studio with
pantera frontman phil and selmo to add
vocals to his current band scour
mamoa's not just gifted with heavy metal
roars either the man is also a guitar
player and there are plenty of photos of
him showing off his latest instruments
or enjoying downtime on set with some
heavy wrists
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you